that's actually a really really
interesting reflection about about
romantic love and its role in colonizing
the wallpaper of your mind if you think
of your mind if you think of your inner
life as a kind of movie right as a kind
of narrative unfolding right your inner
life as cinema then to meet someone that
you fall in love with to meet someone
that takes your breath away is to decide
very quickly you want them in every
scene think about I mean to fall in love
is to decide you want the person around
in every scene you know when I watch a
movie that I love and I fall in love
with the character I never get bored I
want them in every scene I want them to
fill the screen I want them to fill my
inner life and that's what happens when
you partake in a relationship when you
enter into a dance with another person
don't you think my friend when you enter
into a dance when you enter into a dance
with another person you are essentially
saying I want you in every scene I want
you to be the star to be the main
character in my inner life and the
reason I think this is so significant is
because in a way it's a miracle that it
can last right choose your partner
wisely because I mean when I think of
myself it's such a gift of generosity
and a miracle that somebody could ever
find me tolerable for extended periods
of time that they want me as part of the
sort of default reoccurring character in
their movie what a commitment and a
choice and and an invitation to make to
another person and the thing is again I
have no issue with such a thought like
I'm a romantic like when I'm in love I
do want the girl in every scene when I
wake up with her I'm grateful when I
fall asleep next to her I'm grateful
when I watch her get dressed in the
I'm grateful when she comes out of the
shower naked I'm grateful when she
washes her hair I'm grateful when I get
close enough to smell her
I'm grateful when she sits at her
computer and does some work and I'm
grateful I just I'm just grateful she's
in my movie I want to live in that
cosmology and I want her to be the
character that's never not there I have
no problem with this again this is what
love is for me right this kind of
virtual reality this this cosmology
shaped like a heart inhabited by these
two people but then but then my fear
right my terror of abandonment comes
from the insecurities or the belief or
the fear that maybe I'm not lovable
enough to be the star of someone else's
movie like for a girl to pick me to be
in her movie all the time is something
that I just am terrified
I could never fulfill for anyone like
how could she want me in her movie all
the time won't you get bored of me or
what if one day she wakes up and he's
just annoyed at my presence she's just
annoyed at my habits she's just annoyed
at my rhythms
she's just annoyed at my smells he's
annoyed at my farts she's annoyed that
I'm around she's just tired of
what I am she doesn't want me in her
movie anymore she doesn't want me in her
screen anymore and then she abandons me
there's so much drama there because
that's the fear right even though I
don't Harbor
the the the thought that I could ever
stop loving someone I yeah I'm terrified
that someone will stop loving me
Wow I gotta work on that that's um
that's some deep pain I have there and
also some some something I need to kind
of probe and engage with intensely do I
feel that I am deserving of someone
else's love enough for them to want me
in their movie all the time
for them to want me in their movie for
life
because I certainly dream about having
someone in my movie for life to take the
journey with that person and I just
don't know if if I'm willing to believe
in somebody